this has fired up  because  harry decided to actually suck this  in order to be able to complete  development  and um my only question is  actually i have two hey is the queen  coming out b  does white have a lot of counter play on  the dark squares  okay so what's white's next move here  okay so i'm gonna be devil's advocate oh  you have quincy's three of queen c3 this  is the issue  so  um to stop that i mean you can play  bishop b2 but okay yeah and queen takes  queen b3 i don't see that this is an  issue at all for black  okay that's a good punt  at least he's trying to open up the dark  squares  yep  um  is it any good  okay so first things first  knight takes f5  no you can't do that  is it doable  magnus carlsen with black against harry  apparently not they've agreed no  no according to the engine but uh can we  outmuscle the engine  well they've already agreed to draw so  no  oh  okay and that goes to show how sleepy i  am